perfectly normal
erica has been a midwife for over 20
years
come april she will lose her job
that's because she's
unvaccinated i'm personally devastated
on a practical level
um i've got to earn a living so that's
obviously a stress i have colleagues
that are
single parents um and they don't know
where they're going to get the income to
be able to
survive are you
against the vaccine or are you against
the mandate
against the mandate it's been drummed
into us from our training to be
autonomous practitioners and empower
women to make their own decisions
so when we're not being allowed to do
that for ourselves now um
that's making me making people angry
really glad i think ready that this is
my last kind of week
hannah is 36 weeks pregnant and erica
has been there every step of the way
i understand my baby you know and myself
may need ongoing services from the nhs
in the future and you know i know it's
under strain already the impact that may
have
on the availability of care that i need
could definitely be a concern
[Applause]
erica joined hundreds of nhs staff who
marched through central london on
saturday
demanding the mandate to be scrapped
around 77 000 are currently unvaccinated
it's at a particularly difficult time
there's increased sickness there is high
vacancies and there has been pressure on
the nhs in the last
month or so and so in a sense what i'm
really asking for is the deadline of the
first of april to be moved to allow
people to have more time to make those
decisions also a huge amount
erica is hoping for a change in policy
the health secretary says the mandate
has helped to boost the number of nhs
staff getting vaccinated to 95 percent
it is the professional duty of every nhs
worker to get vaccinated is a
professional duty around a hundred
thousand in the nhs that were
unvaccinated at that point that have
come forward so
there's been a very good response
the mandate was introduced to ensure
patient safety okay
soon the health secretary will need to
decide what is more dangerous for the
nhs tens of thousands of unvaccinated
workers or losing them all together
ashish joshi sky news